>>> GET OFF THE ISLAND, BRO.
MY MOM IS GOING TO FREAK OUT.
>> JOHN, THIS PARTY ROCKS.
IT IS LIKE LEGENDARY.
>> I TOLD YOUR MOM NOT TO DRINK.
>> SHE HAS GOTTA, BECAUSE WE ARE
SENIORS NOW.
>> SENIORS.
IT IS SO WEIRD TO SAY THAT,
BECAUSE I AM SO USED TO BEING A
JUNIOR.
>> TOTALLY.
LOOK AT US, GROWING UP.
OH, I GOT MY PENN STATE APP
DONE, BY THE WAY.
>> DUDE, ME TOO, BROTHER.
>> SAME.
>> HELLO, FUTURE ROOMIES.
>> WHAT ABOUT YOU, TOMMY.
YOU DONE WITH THE APP?
>> ACTUALLY, GUYS, THERE'S
SOMETHING I'VE BEEN MEANING TO
TELL YOU.
I AM NOT APPLYING TO PENN STATE.
>> WHAT?
>> OH, MY GOD.
YOU'RE APPLYING TO HARVARD,
AREN'T YOU, PAL?
>> TOMMY.
>> OH, YOU FREAKING BRAINIAC.
>> NO, NO, NO.
GUYS.
LOOK, REMEMBER WHEN I TOLD YOU
THAT I WAS 17?
>> YEAH.
WE ALL ARE.
>> I'M 67.
>> WHAT?
>> I'M 67 YEARS OLD.
>> NO.
YOU'RE 17.
YOU FROM NEW JERSEY.
YOUR NAME IS
TOMMY "PORKCHOP" LUCIANO.
>> MY NAME SEAMUS O'SULLIVAN.
I'M A 67-YEAR-OLD IRISHMAN.
>> SO LET ME GET THIS STRAIGHT,
WHEN WE WOULD SKIP SEVENTH
PERIOD TO SNEAK BEERS, YOU WERE
WHAT?
SOME OLD GUY?
>> THINK ABOUT IT.
WHEN YOU WERE DRINKING THE
CRAPPY BEER, I WAS DRINKING --
>> A GLASS OF WHISKEY WITH A BIG
SQUARE CUBE.
>> OH MY GOD.
BUT PORKCHOP, YOU WERE THE
CRAZIEST KID IN SCHOOL.
I MEAN, YOU DID DRUGS IN CLASS.
>> BYE-BYE.
>> THOSE WERE BLOOD THINNERS.
>> SO, ALL OF THOSE TIMES AFTER
GYM CLASS WHEN WE WERE NERVOUSLY
CHANGING, AND YOU WERE --
WERE --
>> YOU WERE COMFORTABLE BEING
ASS-NUDE.
>> OH, MY GOD.
>> THAT'S JUST THE WAY OLD
FELLOWS ARE.
>> TOMMY, WHY ARE YOU IN HIGH
SCHOOL?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
I JUST GOT LOST.
AND THEN I WATCHED "GOSSIP GIRL"
AND IT JUST SEEMED FUN.
>> WHAT?
COME ON, MAN!
>> YOU WATCHED "GOSSIP GIRL" AND
THEN ENROLLED IN SCHOOL?
>> YOU START "GOSSIP GIRL" AND
THEN YOU ENROLLED IN SCHOOL?
YOU SOUND LIKE MY WIFE.
>> DUDE, YOU HAVE A WIFE?
>> YES, SINCE '77.
DO YOU THINK THEY'LL BE MAD AT
ME?
>> OF COURSE, EVERYBODY'S GOING
TO BE MAD AT YOU.
>> I THINK I THOUGHT OF A NEW
NICKNAME FOR US.
THE CORE FOUR.
>> WE'RE STILL THE CORE FOUR.
>> THE CORE FOUR IS NO MORE.
COME ON, GUYS.
LET'S GO.
>> I DO JUST HAVE ONE QUESTION.
WAS ANY OF THIS REAL?
>> WAS IT REAL?
BEN, WHEN YOU FORGOT YOUR LUNCH
MONEY, WHAT DID I DO?
>> YOU GAVE ME HALF YOUR
CABBAGE.
>> AND WHEN YOU WERE HAVING
BODY-IMAGE ISSUES, WHAT DID I DO
TO MAKE YOU FEEL BETTER?
>> YOU TOOK YOUR SHIRT OFF AND
JUMPED AROUND A LITTLE.
>> JOHN BOY, WHEN YOUR FATHER
PASSED, WHO WAS THERE TO SUPPORT
YOUR FAMILY?
>> YOU.
>> STAYED WITH YOUR MOTHER EVERY
NIGHT.
GIVING HER MASSAGES.
SLEEPING IN HER BED.
>> I DIDN'T KNOW THAT HAPPENED.
>> AYE, YOU'RE MY BOYS.
AND WE'RE ABOUT TO HAVE AN EPIC
SENIOR YEAR!
>> WAIT, YOU'RE STAYING?
WHAT ABOUT YOUR FAMILY?
>> DON'T BE AN ASS.
I'M NOT GOING TO MISS ME SENIOR
YEAR.
NOT WHEN WE FINALLY RUN THIS
SCHOOL.
>> ANYBODY NEED A LIFT?
>> OH!
>> YOU ARE AMAZING.
>> THIS IS FOR YOU.